C'est
il ne vient même pas qu'il n'a pas
ça ne sort même pas d'une fourchette car aujourd'hui c'est le jour de la soupe
réchauffer le fer repasser mes vêtements
dans cette berceuse je vais rompre
secoue secoue secoue secoue tu ne viens même pas
cela n'a pas
ça ne vient même pas des escaliers que tu vois
le tir au sous-sol envoie un matelas parfait
Je vais le mettre à casser dans ce pack
secouer le sac à utiliser
[Musique]
une maison caboclo
Ont-ils dit ou est-ce peu
deux c'est bien de s'embrasser
plus est venu pour garder votre place en ligne
tout homme qui vacille
la femme passe à
Entrez, ne venez même pas, vous n'avez pas
tourner la ligne brûlée grise prend du temps et
montrer que papa part
Je vais le mettre à casser dans ce pack
sac jeans prenant soin de moi sans moquerie et
par
[Musique]
service
une maison caboclo
De petites choses positives y ont été dites
plus aussi
Dis-moi à quelle place dans la file d'attente je suis malade
vaciller l'amour et
passe à
l'acheter ne vient même pas que vous n'en ayez pas
[Musique]